make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are covering
tales from the dark multiverse it's kind
of surprising that dc is still releasing
these but at the same time i'm kind of
not surprised because they were just so
freaking cool
and it kind of sucked that dc stopped
doing it for a time you know but this is
a cool one the next one we get after
this is actually flashpoint so i'm
really excited to see what this has in
store now for those of you guys who are
not familiar
with tales from the dark multiverse a
lot of you guys are familiar with like
the the dark knights metal event right
the idea that you have the multiverse
and dc comics and then
on the opposite side you have the dark
multiverse which is basically worlds
that are not supposed to exist worlds
that are born
from like nightmares and things like
that and so tales of the dark multiverse
was designed to build on that
and it was designed to basically give us
stories involving versions of batman
from the dark multiverse just these
really
terrible and twisted versions of his
character and so what this does is this
initially starts out by kind of giving
us
the typical origin of batman the way
that we normally expect right in the
sense that you've got bruce wayne who's
alongside his parents thomas and martha
after seeing the the mask of zorro
in the process they're basically his
parents are shot to death in crime alley
by joe chill and then bruce wayne
basically goes on to travel the world
learn all kinds of different skills and
then come back to gotham as batman
that's the way it normally works
the way this works is that it wasn't
just bruce thomas and martha
it was also thomas elliott and his
parents now for those of you guys who
don't know who thomas elliott is
thomas elliott made his debut in a story
that was really really awesome called
batman hush
but this was basically a story where
hush popped up out of nowhere and
essentially just like turned all of
batman's villains or really kind of took
all his villains and pit him against
batman
and even some of his allies right and it
was cool stuff like superman falls under
the control of poison ivy it's
just these amazing ways of just kind of
moving characters around in a way that
you don't normally see
and it was literally batman just running
the gauntlet it was it was nuts it's an
amazing story i think it's like 12
issues long or something like that and
so what this does is it basically tells
us that in the aftermath of bruce
wayne's parents dying
that the eliots were the one who took in
bruce instead of alfred
and that as time went on bruce became
more and more disconnected
and fell deeper and deeper into madness
right basically began to kind of lose
his mind and so the result of this
is that we end up picking up some years
later and gotham city
is wholly different now instead of
gotham city being
one of the many cities among the united
states it's now a city state it's
independent of the united states gotham
has its own president it's got its own
defense contractors it really is
its own country and you have people who
play different roles here right the
person who's in charge of gotham's
defense contracting is jason todd the
attorney general of gotham is harvey
dent you know
the founding families the entrepreneur
and the philanthropist the the kind of
big time financial guy
outside of you know the one who runs
wayne enterprises is oswald cobblepot
but really gotham's first family the
richest individuals in gotham are
essentially thomas elliott and talia al
ghul
there's a little bit of importance that
i kind of want to impress upon you guys
here natalia al ghul as you guys know is
the biological mother of damian wayne
and in the main dc universe it was talia
and bruce who ended up having damien
right now this the means by which damien
was was conceived are questionable at
best but the idea behind this is that
talia basically procreated with bruce
in this instance she's with thomas
elliot now the motivation behind that
will actually become a little more
apparent as time
goes on in terms of why she's here but
it's one of these little one of these
interesting things
where it where essentially thomas
elliott is the one who's
basically running wayne enterprises when
enterprises effectively fell to him now
how that happened we'll find out here in
a second but the funny thing about this
is that the reason why talia is
currently with thomas elliott
is because she's still the one who runs
the league of assassins that hasn't
really changed she killed her father
took his place and she's the one who
runs the show but the league of
assassins
serves as a means by which thomas elliot
became a senator right so
using power using information probably
money different things like that they
ended up securing his place
as a senator now we also end up getting
is that where initially our first
inclination here is to like the wealthy
and the powerful of gotham we end up
finding out that things are a lot more
dire than they are
than they initially appear what you have
here is very much a kind of
tsarist society right a bolshevik
revolution type of society in the sense
that when you have the
bolshevik revolution in the early 1900s
in russia
what you had was extreme social
inequality right so you had
the super wealthy in the form of the
tsar the tsar family and those
individuals they consorted with and then
you had
basically everybody else right who was
living in destitution and squalor
and that's why the bolshevik revolution
happened is because you basically had
people who had just had enough and they
revolted against the czars they killed
the entire zar family including
anastasia and then of course we ended up
getting vanguard communism which is a
form of communism that never works but
the idea behind this is that you
basically have this extreme inequality
so you have individuals who are
revolting against the government and
then you have the government itself
which is kind of putting out this
illusion to the general public
everything's fine and look at how great
the upper class is doing and so on and
so forth and so from there we basically
follow eliot when he was called away and
we pick up with dr crane right now dr
crane is normally
scarecrow but this guy's here within
arkham asylum and the idea behind this
is that within arkham most of the
traditional criminals that we're
familiar with have largely just kind of
been locked away
becoming the characters that we know for
example jarvis touch is not actually uh
the mad hatter instead he's just a crazy
guy in a cell who sings these songs
about the devil of arkham right this
kind of rumor or this story
about how there was at one point in time
a force that just kind of moved around
arkham asylum at least it was put
forward by amadeus arkham like the guy
who originally
ran and established the the asylum
itself that it was just kind of this
ghostly apparition that would move
between the walls and and that kind of a
thing right you know
it's kind of creepy in the way that it's
done but the reason why thomas elliot
has been called here is because bruce
wayne has died and he's only the most
recent
in a series of deaths that have happened
within arkham and for the most part it's
just kind of being swept under the rug
they can kind of be explained away but
in this instance it can't right the
indication here is that bruce wayne
basically rolled over on his pillow and
suffocated himself right which is a
little weird but he's got the
the you know autopsy scars and all that
kind of stuff and it's a little crazy
right because
bruce wayne is just officially dead and
so what you end up getting here is this
arrangement that that seems to have
happened
where you essentially had dr crane
working alongside thomas
elliott to kind of keep bruce wayne in a
vegetative state that bruce wayne had
basically been
essentially you know a vegetable for
quite some time now it's not really said
explicitly on the nose like hey reader i
helped thomas elliot keep bruce wayne in
a vegetative state so that thomas
elliott could take over the wayne
fortune
and keep it right because if bruce wayne
just woke up and ward got out you know
even if it somehow managed to leak out
that bruce wayne is within arkham asylum
and he's lucid then people would be like
what's going on here they would start
asking questions right and it would lead
to a great big huge debacle and so
keeping him off the grid
basically kept things silent the other
part of this though is that within the
hand of bruce wayne is a ticket to the
mark of zorro and that's why things are
a little wonky here because it's kind of
like we've never really seen this before
now following that you end up having dr
crane as he leaves and basically comes
across
the groundsman who's largely alluded to
be the joker but then suddenly the
lights kick off
and that's when you end up having this
kind of of you know this
this rhyme that's being given by jarvis
touch which he kind of continues on
in the darkness and where the the
janitor is kind of like okay you know
the lights will kick back on here in a
second you know it's cool it happens
sometimes
it's super late we get these rolling
power outages it's not really that
uncommon that the emergency lights kick
on and like
this just horrifying looking batman
besiege that looks like hush if he
became batman
just comes flying on to on to dr crane
and just
seems to kill the guy it's kind of nuts
following that like thomas elliot bales
right he ends up getting out of there
and getting on this helicopter and
flying back to what looks to be his
penthouse apartment
that you have this batman figure just
perched kind of looking at him when that
happens a rocket shoots out of nowhere
and takes a helicopter down and when
that when the helicopter crashes and
lands
you end up finding out that it kind of
lands among you know you have all these
rebels and so on and so forth but the
rebels are basically led by barbara
gordon and the reason why is because in
the rise to
gotham becoming a city state that her
father jim gordon was killed in the
process
now again we're not given a whole lot of
indication here if we just sort of use a
little bit of a combination of common
sense and a little bit of just kind of
guesswork we can largely assume that
gotham was any city just like any other
and that
something seems to have happened gotham
basically decided to become an
independent city-state
somehow it was allowed and that in turn
led to commissioner gordon possibly a
handful of others becoming part of a
resistance movement and in that process
jim gordon was killed barbara took up
the mantle in his stead and has
basically been fighting ever since
and so when that happens of course you
end up having what's more or less a
gotham city military come to sending on
right
they kind of come to sitting on this
thing but you also end up having tim
drake who's here along with cassandra
kane that these guys are more or less
unified
absent the idea of batman right but
they're still there and they still work
as a singular group in the process
you know with the the the helicopter
crash landing you get uh cassandra kane
you get tim drake who basically show up
here and then they're met by the arrival
of one of the grey sons and the grey son
is dick grayson now it's kind of it's
kind of weird here because grayson
there's actually a really cool concept
of this character that we'll talk about
here in a second but this guy
lays waste to tim drake and cassandra
kane i mean overcomes them like that
it's not even a it's not even a fight
it's not even a contest and he asked tim
drake like do you really want to do this
fight right now because if we do you're
going to die and tim drake is like we'll
fight
but not today and he basically ends up
leaving now we end up finding out that
grey's son and really the grey sons
themselves
seem to work or at least are heavily
involved directly with the president of
gotham president lincoln march which is
a really interesting concept given the
new 52 batman run the cool thing is that
with the great sun being here he's
basically told like i was sent here
directly from the president
because we need to keep an eye on you
right we need to keep an eye on gotham
we have to keep all the stuff under
control and
it's one of the interesting things here
because it's not the first time this has
happened that other individuals out
there right like attorney general harvey
dent was attacked the gia basically the
gotham city
security force right so like their their
paramilitary group captain flash the
ones who
the one who runs it is missing as well
there were these clippings about the old
wayne murders that were found
alongside these individuals or at least
i'm sorry in a place where these
individuals were when they went missing
and so there's a kind of huge mystery
going on here
and that's why thomas elliott was
secured by grayson because it's kind of
like the powerful of gotham are
vanishing we're here to grab you
to make sure that doesn't happen to you
now from there they end up of course
capturing barbara gordon and when grey's
son starts interrogating her
it's this interesting thing where you
kind of find out that hey like her
people did not bring down the airship
they don't really know who did but then
grey's son basically drops the the idea
of like these powerful people are
missing these news clippings are there
and then she's like oh it's the wayne
murders that are reason why
those guys are going missing okay well
it's starting to make a lot more sense
then i'm gonna give you an easy clue
here right and this will put you back on
the path
of actually finding out what's going on
what she tells him is that the airship
of thomas elliot was most likely shot
down by a lexicorp's surface-to-air
rim-72 raptor missile and you cannot
access those in the united states
instead
the only way to get those is outside of
the u.s and the idea is that you can
only find them in
santa prisca and that several containers
of quote-unquote structure grade lumber
from santa prisca
arrived in gotham harbor last week and
the person who received those
is the defense contractor of gotham it's
jason todd and so she
basically points to the finger and says
we don't know who shot you down but it
looks like it was probably jason todd so
you may want to go and investigate him
and then she's like as far as this
assassination attempt that was made on
your life i wouldn't really worry about
that because what it looks like is
you've got
much much bigger problems now what we
end up doing is transitioning to old
town in gotham city an
old town is basically the base of
operations for where jason todd operates
as the defense contractor of course some
pretty heavy hitters some big henchmen
and when they get in there the immediate
question the immediate interrogation
from greyson
is what's going on here why is it that
you're receiving missiles and so on and
so forth and we initially have jason
todd who's like i don't really know what
you're talking about i have no idea
what's going on grayson basically says
like well we could say dick grayson
basically says look i've got my drones
that are going through here and they're
they're scanning your entire facility
right and they found 12 lux corp
ordnance containers containing these
missiles and one of the missiles are
gone
right so by all standards of measurement
this missile came from your facility and
it was used to try to shoot down a
sitting senator
spill the beans on what's going on right
and literally like targets his drones on
him with the intention of killing him
following that you end up having all
these forces to start showing up and
they're actually members of the league
of assassins which are led by talia al
ghul and that's when jason todd starts
to spill the beans and saying sorry man
it's the end of the road for you
right like the owls have had their time
right so this points to the idea that
dick grayson
is actually part of the court of owls
now the court of owls have moved beyond
gotham city and
i'm sorry moved up in gotham city under
effectively seem to be the ones running
the show here or at the very least are
heavily involved in president lincoln
march which kind of makes sense given
his involvement with the court of owls
in the events of new 52
but with the court of owls having long
been the secretive organization that
worked within gotham city itself that
that
that kind of concept still continues on
and so jason todd is kind of like this
is the end of the road man well then
suddenly out of nowhere a grenade comes
flying in right and like the whole place
starts to burn and when that happens
like you've got thomas elliott and
you've got dick grayson who basically
get out of there as fast as they can
when the batman comes pouring in and
starts tearing into everybody now for
his part dick grayson fights against
batman as best he can but he's not much
of a
of a competitor here right and so of
course he basically ends up escaping
you've gotta you've got you know batman
who immediately goes after jason todd
and jason todd here's the thing man
jason todd goes down like a hero and not
even like a here he just goes down like
the most awesome way ever he's like he's
like do you really think i'll go down
easy he's like come on then right he's
like come on big boy let's
dance and then just start shooting right
it's the craziest thing
it's the coolest thing well following
that revelation from jason todd
thomas elliott ends up inside wayne
manor goes running up on talia and he's
like what's going on here right like
she's like i
was like where have you been i have no
idea what you're talking about he's like
i just got done talking with jason tom
when all hell broke loose and he told me
that the league of assassins is gonna
take me out and they're led by you
and he did it with your blessing so the
two of you are working together to oust
me
so what in the heck is going on here and
her response is the league of assassins
did not have any attempt on your life
but do not misunderstand your place in
the bigger picture
thomas elliot we put you where you are
and we have plans for you we would like
to put you in the position of president
of gotham but we also recognize that you
could be killed at any point in time and
so we've got backup plans for our backup
plans and we needed jason todd's
resources right it just happened to be
that jason todd decided to make that
move against you right then because he
has his own ambitions you know and that
kind of a thing it's kind of crazy
because the response of thomas elliot is
if you want to maintain access to my
multi-billion dollar company then you
would do well to keep me alive well in
saying that he suddenly looks on his
desk and realizes there's a comic for
the mark of zorro and he's like
where did you get this and that's when
he starts freaking out talia has no idea
what he's talking about right she
doesn't know anything about this batman
type character she thinks
he's losing his mind and he's like this
batman's guy's been in this house right
he's been in this house before
this all started in one place i'm going
back there and we're gonna finally get
answers right so he ends up going back
to what's basically
wayne manor the original wayne manor
house and when he gets in there he
starts asking the question like who are
you
why are you doing all this and he's met
by this voice and this this voice says
is there something i should know about
the wayne murders and that's what we end
up finding out that dick grayson's here
and the reason why he's here is because
he tracked down thomas elliott that he's
got a bug on thomas elliot so he can
overhear what he says and he's got a
tracker so he can always know where his
movements are and given the conversation
he had with talia and given the
given his movements it was only a matter
of logic that he would end up here
not only that that where dick grayson is
the head of president march's security
that what you end up finding out is that
president march and those guys had long
believed
for quite some time that the league of
assassins working alongside thomas
elliott
intended to move him above his station
and replace president lincoln march and
so it was kind of like we suspected that
for a long long time and now you have
basically confirmed it through your
conversations with talia that you plan
on ousting the president and taking his
place well in the middle of all that the
floor comes crashing down right
literally they get
yanked through the floor and when they
basically begin to come to the thomas
elliott looks around
and sees alfred and he's singing this
this really creepy nursery rhyme hush
little babe
lest you call down the bloody bat of
gothamtown he lurks above
desiring of a corpse to plant beneath
the ground he knows your heart your
blackest deed
and follows them wherever they lead
where you go the bat will know
and find you with the devil's speed it's
a really cool rhyme like i
love that rhyme right and thomas elliott
does not immediately recognize
alfred and this really kind of shows the
fact that thomas didn't have a whole lot
of involvement with alfred and alfred
has largely been absent
in the the years since thomas took over
wayne enterprises all that kind of stuff
and so what you end up what you end up
having happen is that alfred basically
tells thomas
it was a mistake coming here right it
was a terrible terrible mistake and when
the lights kick on
there's one this this holding cell
that's here that looks like it's
intended for uh for whoever the next
victim is seemingly thomas himself and
then you've also got like all these
other
other individuals who are currently
being held here jason todd's being held
here
all these folks right like like dr crane
is being held here and that's when the
bat starts to
start to pop up because thomas asked the
question like alfred did you do all this
and the response of alfred is no i'm
just a humble humble man servant i serve
the waynes
nothing more and then he says the wings
are dead alfred and the response of
alfred is are they master thomas
are they really dead indeed and then you
end up having this batman who shows up
here right now
batman literally goes after thomas and
says like i know what you did tommy
right all those years ago your family
driver what you promised him to kill
your own parents and how it all went
wrong
who else and what tom is like who are
you he's like who else would i be
everyone's dead but us the wanes are
dead in that alley the eliots were
killed on the road a few years later the
driver was killed in a cell awaiting
trial for another crime even the decent
cop who took the call
jim gordon is dead and he says when your
parents took me in your mother said
the boys will finally get to be real
brothers how dr crane laughed
when i told him that story the idea that
i was ever like a brother to you who
took
every single thing from me this is bruce
wayne right
like thomas has worked against bruce
from the beginning right that thomas
seemed to have wanted to take his
take his parents out and then to take
out the the parents of bruce and take
over the wayne fortune for himself and
and the response to thomas is you're
dead i saw you die you were on the
operating table you had an autopsy done
on you you had the autopsy scars and
that's when he says no
this was all planned from the very
beginning you were not the only visitor
in arkham tommy right alfred was
always with me and he says so was the
handyman that we planted at arkham
jack napier this is the guy who gave me
the surgical scars that made it look
like i had an autopsy right so i could
basically fake my death and escape that
place he gave me the drugs so i could
look like i died he says with alfred's
help i learned what happened to my
parents
years ago and napier got me access to
people in arkham who could help me
avenge them
all these individuals who were held
within arkham asylum amadeus arkham
himself
who taught criminal psychology the
disgraced spy nick mason who taught him
disguise lock picking all things
spycraft all these individuals played a
role
in bruce wayne becoming who he was
becoming this version of batman that's
dark and twisted and knowing how to kill
people with surgical precision and
disappear without
ever being caught and so you initially
have thomas who begs right he's like no
no you misunderstand you misunderstand
right
we're brothers man and together we can
fix everything we can fix gotham we can
make it a better place man we can make
it better than what it used to be and
the response is
no that's not going to happen you're
never going to see the light of day
again right this is it you're finished
and so from there you switch back over
to
kind of like the the gotham state media
right which is kind of going through and
saying hey like you know here's here's
everything that's going on
you know and that the you know with the
the vanishing of thomas elliott the
wayne fortune is passed on to alfred
pennyworth who was a family butler but
nobody's seen him in years so we have no
idea where this billionaire is or what
it is that he has going on
that talia al ghul is now on the arm of
president lincoln march right she's with
him now you know many of us thought
talia would seek out the affections of
jason todd but he's gone and it seems
like it's pretty fast right she just
immediately jumped after the vanishing
of thomas elliott directly into the arms
of lincoln march right so hypergamy
and it's just kind of like this is
pretty wild right like it's pretty crazy
stuff
it's interesting because what you end up
finding out here is the handyman
is the one who basically kind of guards
all these cells so basically
the joker of sorts that alfred is just
kind of there keeping the place cleaned
up as as trashed as it is and that
basically batman the silence which is
what he's called now is traveling
throughout gotham
and killing all this all the higher
powered guys all the folks who are
running the show and who are completely
and totally corrupted what the end goal
is we have no clue we have no clue if he
wants to just distill
madness throughout the entirety of the
city but whatever it is this is in
effect
a version of bruce wayne who's
experienced torment who was broken by
madness who completely and totally
lost his mind in the face of the fact
that he had completely
lost everything with that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you